The
idea of paying for yourself when out with
friends being referred to as some expression
including the word “Dutch,” seemingly
incorrectly is often connected to the fact
that for several centuries beginning in the
17th, the word Dutch had a negative connotation
in English, variously meaning cheap, duplicitous,
alcoholic, poor, treacherous, selfish or just
plain wrong.
The derogatory usage of “Dutch” stems
from animosity between the English and Dutch
due to their competing positions as naval
powers, which would ultimately erupt into
full on wars, mostly fought at sea.
It’s no surprise then that by the middle
of the 17th century when war broke out, the
English had come up with some choice derogatory
expressions related to their rivals.
Specifically, by 1654, the first derogatory
uses of Dutch began appearing in print, such
as R. Whitlock’s Zworouia: “The contract
is not (like Dutch Bargains) made in Drinke.”
Soon, phrases such as Dutch palate (1687 meaning
low class) and Dutch reckoning (1699 meaning
poor accounting, particularly a bill that
doesn’t include details and potentially
becomes bigger if you question it) were also
appearing.
That said, contrary to what is often said,
none of this appears to have anything to do
with the various “Dutch” expressions meaning
to pay for one’s self.
In fact, the origin of this expression might
even have little to do with what we think
of today as “Dutch” at all.
In the 17th and 18th centuries, many German-speaking
groups immigrated to the United States.
For those that settled in Pennsylvania, they
became known as Pennsylvania Dutch.
As to why these German-speaking people were
called this in the first place, for some time
in English, High Dutch generally referred
to people from parts of Germany and nearby
mountainous regions and Low Dutch got applied
to people from the Netherlands, at the time
with these regions part of the Holy Roman
Empire.
Even after they gained their respective independence,
the naming scheme still stuck around for a
while in certain places, like America.
In the United States, it would seem that the
Pennsylvania Dutch had a reputation for never
owing anyone anything to the point that, even
with a group of friends in a tavern, the reputation
was that each person would pay his own bill.
Whether this reputation is wholly accurate
or not, in the United States, various phrases
that included the word “Dutch” became
synonymous with this characteristic and eventually
different variations with the meaning began
to appear in print, including: “Dutch treat”
(1873), “Dutch lunch” (1897) and “go
Dutch” (1914).
For instance, the earliest documented instance
of the first of these line of expressions
appeared in the Daily Democrat on June 27,
1873:
If our temperance friends could institute
what is called the “Dutch treat” into
our saloons, each man paying his reckoning,
it would be a long step towards reforming
in drinking to excess.
The next up was the “Dutch lunch,” with
the first known instance appearing in the
Fort Wayne Morning Journal on October 24,
1897,
Perhaps you have a fatter pocketbook than
some of the other fellows.
I, for instance, can’t afford to buy two
tickets every time I go.
So some of the boys and I go on the “Dutch
lunch” plan: everybody for himself.
Interestingly, at the same time these expressions
were taking on their figurative sense, they
were also occasionally used literally, as
in describing the food eaten by the Pennsylvania
Dutch.
To wit, an 1894 newspaper report found by
esteemed etymologist Michael Quinion of the
truly phenomenal World Wise Words notes that
a “Dutch supper,” should include rye bread,
cabbage salad, Wienerwursts, and beer “consistently
expressive of [the] vaterland.”
Given that this line of “Dutch X” expressions
didn’t appear until the late 19th to early
20th centuries; they first appeared in the
United States, rather than Britain; they seem
in many cases to be referring to Pennsylvania
Dutch; and they aren’t inherently derogatory,
it’s thought by many etymologists that,
contrary to what is often said, these expressions
probably had nothing to do with the former
lineup of derogatory “Dutch X” expressions
invented by the British a couple centuries
before.